hey what is up guys I'm cabby HD here
and so as I read all your tweets and
collect video of as promised the best
stuff at CES I stumbled upon the
Panasonic booth and you'll never guess
what I found there
yeah the legendary Tesla Model S caught
my eye stopped me and then I got a
little carried away staring at it
because it's just such a good looking
car but I figured I'd share this one
with you guys a little fun video while
the other tech goodness is on its way to
your subscription box right now so
thumbs up for that but basically yeah
this is the one and only for those of
you who don't know if you don't follow
me on Twitter or Instagram or Google+ or
Facebook or really any of the places
that I've said this I'm a really big fan
of the Tesla like I've liked it for a
long time and I think it's safe to say
that this electric car is my favorite
car out there of any cars and I'm not
the only one who likes the Model S it
was actually catching a lot of people's
eyes at the booth with Panasonic because
of that center console you got to look
inside and see that it's just a 17 inch
touchscreen on the inside instead of
just your typical bunch of dials and
knobs like a regular car has bustle a
whole bunch of other features about the
car we're catching people's eye - turns
out this beauty was at the Panasonic
booth because the battery cells in the
bottom that actually powered the car are
made by Panasonic a lot of people forget
that Panasonic is actually also a
battery company so anyway I don't get to
see these often but I definitely plan on
doing more in-depth videos on the Tesla
Model S or even the Model X or anything
else I can get my hands on to get a
better idea of what it's all about for
you guys but some of you guys live in
California or near the headquarters or
whatever and get to see them all the
time I am jealous of you guys but anyway
yeah even with all the awesome cars I've
seen at CES 2014 so far this might be my
favorite one or the one at least that
I'm most excited about well except for
maybe this one or this one
maybe I should do a montage of all of
them or something either were just a
quick little fun video a piece of tech I
figured I'd share more CES coverage
coming right up thanks for watching guys
and I'll talk to you guys in the next
one peace
[Music]